hi there steve kaufman here um it's a
great day here in vancouver i was up
skiing at cypress
winter wonderland up on the mountain and
yet it's springtime here in vancouver
uh the snow conditions were just
tremendous
uh just a couple of things uh today i
want to talk about
this whole issue of shortcuts to
language learning but before that i just
thought i'd mention that tomorrow i'm
hoping to do a video
interview with susanna ryski
and if the technology works i'll put it
up on my channel
we've also completed the
series of well essentially the same
video
explaining to people just what they're
expected to do at link and i've just
recorded it in different languages and
i've put it up
uh here on my youtube channel
so you can have a look at it and
depending on what your native language
is you can hopefully understand a little
bit more about lake
um we've had some active discussion on
our link forums
uh about uh things you know uh the usual
discussion what's the best way to work
learn languages
and some people like to study grammar in
traditional ways some people like to
speak from the beginning incidentally i
made contact with robert who's a very
accomplished polyglot from austria
and who's also a simultaneous
simultaneous interpreter
and i'm going to talk to him and
hopefully again put it up as a youtube
video so that we'll see you know
different people with different
perspectives on language learning
and there will be areas where we all
agree in areas where we disagree and
that's a good thing i mean it's nice
that people have different uh
perspectives and different things that
they like to do
and so getting back to the discussions
that we've had at our forum at link
um some people say you got to speak
right away other people say no you
shouldn't you have the extreme silent
period people who say it's harmful to
speak
and so forth
and there are people you know on the
internet who have you know uh i think it
was i can't remember his name
who said that he can deconstruct any
language in 60 minutes and that enables
him to learn it very quickly
uh just by using certain certain um you
know
sentences
um
and i know moses mccormick has some such
approach
and
who else was there uh benny of course
with his speak you know and then become
fluent in hurry and and many of these
people are
are good linguists they're good
accomplished polyglots so obviously
whatever they like to do works for them
but in my opinion there are no shortcuts
there are no hacks language hacks as
many puts it there is no deconstructing
the language
essentially there are the three staples
number one your attitude
number two the time you put in and
number three your ability to notice
what's going on in the language
so
yeah obviously no one's going to argue
that
unmotivated people are going to have a
very tough time learning
but the second issue is time it takes
time it takes a lot of time so if you're
willing to put in five or six hours a
day
you'll go more quickly
if you only have one hour a day
it'll take longer and it can take months
and months and even years at that rate
depending of course on what your goals
are
if your goal is to be able to say a few
simple sentences and even to say them
grammatically correctly you can learn to
do that quite quickly
however you have no control over what
the person is going to
say back to you
and the chances are you won't understand
what that person says or at least
once the conversation gets beyond
you know how old are you what's your
name
uh you're gonna be lost
uh to get to where you can actually
carry on a conversation takes time time
with the language
and uh
i don't think really that sitting in a
classroom where
a lot of the conversation is in your
native language counts
i think
personally that studying
uh declension tables
or other things written in my language
to me that doesn't represent
time with the language
if you can spend five hours a day with
speakers of the language surrounded by
the language speaking a little bit you
will improve quickly
if you add to that some deliberate
learning activities on your own you know
where you sort of
are aware of what you didn't understand
and the vocabulary that you're missing
and then you go and look for it and you
get right back in there with these
people so that you're you're you're
constantly with the language you're
spending time with the language you will
improve
uh you have to put in the time and we
see that here as i've said many times
immigrants who go to their esl school
language school but then don't do
anything outside the classroom they
don't improve
and i've also mentioned the situation in
europe i was told at a conference that
uh a majority of corporate language
learners they spend an hour in
class with an instructor and then an
hour to an hour and a half on their own
they won't improve you have to put in
the time i do not believe that there are
shortcuts language hacks deconstruction
read the dictionary study the grammar
study a word list and away you go i
don't believe it whenever i have spent
time and i do
and have you know reading grammar
explanations studying declension tables
you know at best i can retain that till
tomorrow
but not much beyond
they have done studies that show that if
you take two groups of learners and one
group gets a list of vocabulary
uh you know unfamiliar words
uh for a text they're about to read or
listen to and another group does not get
the vocabulary list
and then they're exposed to this text
ask to read it or listen to it there is
no appreciable difference between the
ability of these two groups to
understand what they're listening to are
reading because they can't retain
those vocabulary lists so there's a lot
of that kind of activity where
i don't know what the best term is for
that it's just sort of
uh
deliberately trying to stuff something
in your head
in the hope that it will stick very
little of it sticks
in my experience
uh
the other thing is that a lot of these
and memory systems and flash carding and
all these things
if you like doing them fine and to me
the biggest thing is to do things that
you like to do
because if you like doing them you'll
continue doing them
if you don't like doing them
you won't continue doing them and
therefore they will have
relatively little effect and
uh you know every so often the
traditionalists language teachers fight
back i was on another website where some
language teacher was
challenging me he said you know saying
like how do you measure the success of
students at link and i say well it
depends how happy they are if they're
happy then i'm happy
oh he said you can't compare
the learner's satisfaction you can't i
think you use the word conflate or
something
you know whatever
to me the word is equate he says you
can't conflate
learner satisfaction and
uh achievement
well from my point of view
if i'm a learner to me achievement is to
enjoy what i'm doing and and feel that
i'm communicating better than i was
before
i don't need to have a teacher test me
personally
if someone who wants someone wants to go
out and be tested go and take a test
that's fine but if people at link say
we're satisfied we're learning more than
we did before we understand more than we
did before i'm happy
i'm happy why should
why should i require that person to take
a test
uh so a lot of these traditionalists uh
come back
and uh and say uh you know that the old
way of learning learning grammar once
you learn this was the quote once you
learn the cases you have them well no if
it were that simple then i would
try to do it but i've tried i don't have
them
i look at those cases in russian with
all the different endings and after many
times of looking at that table and
reading the rules i don't have them but
after
much exposure eventually between the
exposure and the occasional review it
starts to sit stick you don't have them
because you learned because you studied
them that's simply not true for me but
it may be true for some other people but
i just wanted to say that i think that
there are no shortcuts i think it takes
time and because it takes a lot of time
you're better off to do things that you
like to do because that way you'll
continue doing it so that the study of
the language becomes its own reward and
if you put in the time you will
certainly improve
so there you have it
on a very nice
day here in vancouver thank you for
listening